[Musique]
à
mais
m
et
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir vous venez de découvrir avec moi
le décor de cette nouvelle émission star
à la barque avec catherine barma et
thierry ardisson nous allons vous
proposer une fois par mois star à la
barre c'est et vous allez vous en rendre
compte tout au long de cette émission
au fil des minutes un tribunal pas tout
à fait comme les autres avec des invités
avec leurs témoins leurs avocats et puis
un jury
un jury composé de sept personnes
généralement dans les tribunaux il est
composé de neuf personnes
mais il a été sélectionné ce jury de la
même manière qu'on sélectionne des jurés
pour n'importe quel tribunal ce jury va
devoir ce soir répondre à deux séries de
questions au cours de deux audiences
différentes sur le même thème le mariage
alors la première audience je peux vous
le garantir ne devrait pas être trop
triste la deuxième en revanche sera
beaucoup plus sérieuses et c'est d'un
programme un problème grave que nous
traiterons celui des mariages mixtes
pour cette série sur les mariages mixtes
nous aurons pour la première fois dans
l'histoire de la télévision deux avocats
qui viendront plaidé en direct devant
des caméras
il s'agit de mettre paul lombard et
maître jacques vergès
nous ouvrons donc la première audience
avec le premier avocat
je ne sais pas si on dit premier avocat
au premier avocate sylvie joly et des se
disent monsieur le président les 219
pages vous appeler maître ou maîtresse
m enfin si vous m'appelez dans
l'intimité je préfère que ma fille est
maîtresse l'autre avocat de cette
première audience c'est le plus nul des
avocats il nous a été prêtée par canal+
c'est alain chabat bonsoir m chabarot
fort
vous avez été un peu libéré de nulle
part ailleurs j'ai l'impression que vous
y voit plus élevé on a arrêté la
quotidienne au début de l'année ce qui
permet de se consacrer à des émissions
spéciales dont la première aura lieu le
26 novembre prochain
chaque année on parle également de la
nuit la plus nulle et lin disque avec
barclays voyez qu'on n'est pas rancunier
pour l'organiser merci beaucoup je vais
appeler la première de nos stars à la
barre ce soir monsieur eddy barclay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir eddie barclay je suis désolé de
vous convoquer
à la barre et non pas au bar j'ai
l'impression que c'est un endroit que
vous préférez généralement nettement
mieux ce qu'il faut derrière la très
bien en réalité vous appelez edouard
ruault
oui c'est mon choix non mais oui vous
avez 67 ans actuellement vous êtes selon
le who's who et c'est notre référence
ici à stara la barre vous êtes chef
d'orchestre compositeur est entre autres
choses mais on peut trouver d'autres
professions oui le producteur de biche
que producteur d'émissions de télévision
éventuellement vous avez découvert pas
mal de grands talents si j'ai bien lu
votre biographie on peut évoquer
quelques noms rapidement comme ça vous
les connaissez
ça a été les plus grands de la chanson
française pendant 35 ans inclus nos amis
jacques brel aznavour léo ferré jean
ferrat claude nougaro nicoletta dalida
très beau palmarès mais c'est d'un autre
palmarès que nous allons parler ce soir
et dimanche les gens nus peur celui de
vos mariages vous êtes mariée huit fois
donc vous avez divorcé cette fois vous
pratiquez pas at-il le ski le tennis de
table et la pétanque que c'est toujours
vrai toujours bois et vous avez 40
l'amour l'amour et l'amour
et pourtant vous avez dirais-je 46 ans
d'écart avec avec votre femme actuelle
caroline mais oui je suppose que vous
aurez tout ça merci au club et
revêtements fiche c'est que je suis très
content comme ça je vais vous demander
de rejoindre votre avocat maître joli
car je vais appeler notre deuxième star
à la barre ce soir danièle gilbert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir daniel bonsoir ça vous ennuie
que je donne votre avis
pas du tout pas du tout je le dis j'ai
déjà donné des ados vous dit en quelque
sorte je crois que la femme d'eddie
barclay puce moi eh bien ça fait l'âge
de 10 bars clubs accorde donc ça fait 45
ans pour vous cela vous concerne vous
êtes selon vous je vous toujours
animatrice productrice à la télévision
c'est toujours vrai nom c'est plus rare
à feu puis tout à fait ça c'est vos
diplômes licence d'allemand diplôme de
l'université de heidelberg
oui et entre autres et lettres
supérieures hypokhâgne très bien vous
avez fait une carrière avec midi
magazine 12h30 vous a été proposé mais
j'avais commencé avant avant bien avant
les patines errance éléments baird
oui j'avais été élue par les
téléspectateurs auvergne a gelé noter
vous avez écrit un livre qui s'appelle
je reviendrai mais j'ai pas dit quand
bon bah on attend toujours
en tous les cas il ya françois avait
fait 1
un référendum pour votre retour oui 1984
oui venez du résultat 97,9 % pour et
pourtant ça n'a pas suffi et il y avait
été sept jours aussi très bien merci
beaucoup daniel gilbert vous allez vous
asseoir à côté du plus nul des avocats
alain chabat qui vous attendait mais
qu'est-ce que je laime à bras ouverts
alors je rappelle les trois questions et
je venais les trois questions que qui se
posent au jury ce soir la première est
la suivante la vie d'edie barkley est
elle un échec ou une réussite
deuxième question l'avis de daniel
gilbert est elle un échec ou une
réussite et troisième question est il
bon d'un petit peu la conséquence des
deux premières est il bon d'être marié
en 1988
mais tout d'abord je vous propose un
premier document qu'il faut verser au
dossier des 10 marqués juillet 45 eddie
barclay épouse michel baroux pour s'en
séparer trois ans et cinq mois plus tard
2 août 49 c'est le tour de la citoyenne
nicole van den bussche madame barclay
pendant 12 ans dès l'exploit re 30 juin
65 c'est marie steinberg qui a la joie
d'annoncer à son entourage ses noces
féerique avec le barbe bleue de
l'industrie phonographique de cette
union qui dure à 55 mois naquit un
superbe bébé
singes ou 1,70 béatrice chatelier
nouvelle madame barclay une bien belle
plante dont il divorcera pour épouser
deux ans plus tard michel des mazures
celle qui assure décidément barclays ne
sais plus quel prétexte invoqué pour
rencontrer une fois de plus sont
désormais amis le maire de
neuilly-sur-seine 80 de la collection
s'enrichit d'une pièce avec la ruse et
daniel poinsot qu'il quittera seize mois
plus tard pour convoler de justes noces
avec mademoiselle cathy esposito 7e
madame barclay un bien beau couple qui
se séparera trois ans plus tard avec
l'arrivée de caroline 20 ans qui
deviendra l'espace d'une inoubliable
cérémonie la huitième madame eddie
barclay
celui-ci portant gaillard de morts ses
67 ans et n'en déplaise à corneille la
valeur attend souvent le nombre des
années
li barclay vous êtes ému quand vous
voyez toutes ces images de
tout beau mariage oui c'est beaucoup
beaucoup d'amour beaucoup d'amour
ouvrait sur tout alors il ya une
question beaucoup plus terre à terre que
se pose la plupart des gens est ce que
lorsque vous divorcez vous verser de
l'argent et vous donnez une pension à
tous vos ex femme
c'est arrivé je suis plus souvent tout
quand j'ai jamais laissé dans la misère
évidemment ça va vous coûter cher non
relativement
m joly c'est un dossier bien noire que
nous venons de découvrir d'entendre et
de voir
alors est-ce que vous avez quelque chose
à dire pour la défense des dix barclay
et bien et tu dis je le connais depuis
qu'il est tout petit bon qu'est ce qui
faisait toute la journée mais il était
assis à la terrasse du café de la poste
le café de moments barkley a regardé les
couples déambuler sur le boulevard est
ça qui aurait créé chez lui un
rapprochement d'idées les coupes le
chiffre toujours des deals qu'un jour il
m'a dit y'a du chiffre à faire là dessus
la tille parler des couples de
l'accouplement au sens du mariage
bien sûr c'est pour ça qu'au quatrième
match on a vraiment décidé de se
structurer
et nous avons monté la barclays wedding
campagne si vous voulez la barclays
mariage compagnie et simultanément mon
fils michel a ouvert une filiale
c'est la barclays braking compagnie
autrement dit la barclays rupture aux
veines du verbe to break cassé non car
qui dit wedding dit breaking c'est le
pendant si vous voulez faire du chiffre
vous faites du wedding mariés suivis de
breaking voka c'est là ne va pas salon
imb hombre thing peut coûter jusqu'à 150
mille dollars
ne l'oublions pas alors tout et breaking
avec les chamailleries comme il y avait
pas mal de casse briques glace bris de
vaisselle
donc on a monté une petite structure de
miroiterie porcelaine légère mais qui
n'a porte bien et surtout nous avons un
support psychothérapique car le breaking
la rupture entraîne des lézardes alors
c'est liliane la cause indédit une
suissesse charmante non mais la nta une
terre de travail attention maintenant ça
se passe parfaitement raid vous
inquiétez pas on aurait dit et moi on
adore on a horreur de dire de
l'illégalité
liliana donc vers un petit centre de
soin qu'on appelle la polyclinique of
barclays salle ecological breaké pour
les jeunes divorcés et leur entourage
et ça marche très très bien ma position
et sa jeudi à l'heure actuelle où tout
le monde cherche des idées pour créer
des emplois nous monsieur le président
marclay entre toutes les filles nous
employons 427 personnes à poste fixe
économiquement c'est un boom énorme
quand on voit des gens comme danièle
gilbert qui est là qu est ce qu elle
représente par rapport à ça je pose la
question
économiquement elle pèse quoi elle va
acheter deux boîtes pour son chien et
pour son jeu est sorti de la coi
qu'est-ce qu'elle crée comme emploi
médiatiquement nous ont un travail
harassant et qui offre son corps en
pâture à la liesse populaire
après certains voyages de noces
je voudrais que vous voyez l'état
physique dans lequel il est il est
complètement aplati
si vous saviez ce qu'ils déboursent mais
c'est dingue
si les 10 ou 15 millions de français
ils sont actuellement sur le marché du
travail je veux dire sur le marché du
mariage avec le cran de se marier au
rythme de barclay mais la france ça
serait disney world
ça ferait de barclays world mieux peu
lieu le festival de rio
il y aurait 250 milles mariage par jour
un mariage qui étaient trente secondes
les pâtissiers les photographes les
couturières les psychiatres les notaires
les orchestres les avocats peu d'oxygène
dans ce monde là c'est pour ça et 10 -
qui connaît l'oeuvre que tu es en train
d'accomplir d'essayer d'accomplir pour
ton pays
quand je vois qu'on cherche des poux
dans la tête aujourd'hui j'ai envie de
dire j'ai envie de dire
il nous reste encore beaucoup de chemin
à parcourir
alors ne me laisseront pas ai dit
monsieur eddy et surtout toi
votre came s'il vous plaît merci m joly
j'ai vu un sourire sur le visage de
daniel gilbert et pourtant j'ai
également un document très noir à verser
à votre dossier
oui mais vous savez l'esprit de dérision
commence parfois même alors je suis
aguerrie à tous allons-y pour les images
cette charmante première communion ne
fera quelques années plus tard la double
page centrale d'un magazine libertin la
grande duduche fut révélée par son
premier amour dénommé jacques martin
déception elle se réfugie entre les
pattes de yuki le toutou qu'il est joli
après une brève incursion en politique
daniel atteint son zénith en 1981 date
un état de grâce qui avait marqué sa
disgrâce émis de vous dire au revoir
et puis je voudrais vous dire qu'on ne
comprend pas tellement pourquoi on nous
a demandé de partir
et puis que nous n'avons rien d'autre à
près et puis après tout il faut vivre
d'espoir et puis qu'il faut être gay et
je vous promets que les émissions de
demain et d'après demain seront gay
parce que c'est ce qu'on vous doit à
vous public qui nous donné tant de joie
1987 la pure danièle gilbert dont dans
les griffes du diable en l'occurrence
celle de l'infâme pornographe professeur
choron qui révèle l'ex star dû 12h30
sous un nouvel angle flambeaux qui sera
repris quelques semaines plus tard par
le non moins cochon magazine lui qui
offre aux regards lubriques de ses
lecteurs une danielle gilbert drôlement
culotté
bien qu'elles ne portent justement pas
de culotte certains ragots prétendent
que le célèbre producteur de films x
marc dorcel l'aurait contacté pour être
la future vedette blanche fesses et les
sept nains affaire à suivre de près
ce dossier noir c'est pas trop loin non
non mais je pense simplement que celui
qui a fait le film un peu obsédé et tout
comme obsédé danièle gilbert au hasard
reprenons ici un star à la barre au
hasard de revue il y en a eu d'autres il
a occulté sans faire de jeu de mots
d'autres revues peut-être peut-être
danièle gilbert
je crois quand même que votre votre
image a évolué depuis
depuis que vous faisiez de la télévision
depuis 1981 et beaucoup même si vous
voulez je n'ai jamais cherché à avoir
une image et simplement évolué en tant
qu'être humain c'est tout il ya deux
façons de faire ce métier c'est d'avoir
une image et d'essayer de coller à cette
image ou bien tout simplement de se
contenter d'exister c'est ce que j'ai
voulu faire mettre chabat vous avez
quelque chose à dire pour la défense de
votre cliente danièle gilbert tout à
fait votre honneur
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
votre honneur m de quoi est accusée ma
cliente
ma cliente est accusé de célibat elle
n'est pas mariée
mesdames et messieurs les jurés ma
cliente vous la connaissez ou du moins
vous pensez la connaître on a vu à
travers ses reportages l'auvergne
chamalières une licence d'allemand
hypokhâgne la grande duduche un mètre
soixante dix au garrot montée comme
annan de passage à cacher une grande
fille très simple
[Applaudissements]
on croit tout savoir d'elle pensait
qu'elle est vide et de la télé en 1981
par un certain pouvoir pour raisons
politiques on sait qu'elle est réintégré
en 86 par un certain pouvoir pour
raisons professionnelles
non sur ce point la presse a été unanime
coupe de l'humanité à paris match
unanimes vous me direz de l'humanité
paris-match pas mélanger les torchons un
petit lien avec les serviettes
périodiques et vous aurez raison
je suis tout à fait d'accord mesdames et
messieurs les jurés combien de fois avez
vous entendu des sarcasmes sur ma
cliente mille fois cent mille fois des
millions ma cliente et gourde nunuche
voire même con comme une [ __ ] en prêtant
aux jeunes entendu toutes ces choses ans
prétend qu'elle a tourné 76 fois autour
d'un pâté de maison parce que son
clignotant était coincé
on raconte qu'à la question avez vous lu
shakespeare elle a répondu non c'est de
qui j'ai entendu toutes ces choses j'ai
entendu toutes ces choses mesdames et
messieurs les jurés
votre honneur m j'ai la preuve ici que
toutes les insinuations sur la prétendue
bêtise de ma cliente sont fausses alors
là normalement quand un avocat dit j'ai
entendu en général le jury gens font
donc si vous pouvez juste me faire donc
je leur fais mesdames et messieurs les
jurés
votre honneur m j'ai la preuve que
toutes ces insinuations sur la prétendue
bêtise de ma cliente sont fausses
pas mal faudrait peut-être moi j'aurais
mis hockey avouer que je ne suis pas la
preuve la voici
mademoiselle danièle gilbert 7 115 x 833
attendu donnez-moi de seconde
595 1500 95 m vous pouvez vérifier votre
honneur excusez moi c'est exact m
nous sommes d'accord c'est bien la
preuve flagrante monsieur le président
que ce n'est pas comme certains porsche
france par peur
ce n'est pas comme certains pensent que
donc parce qu'elle est donc qu est ce
que je suis ni tes rêves voilà tout à
fait c'est une littéraire et ce n'est
pas parce qu'elle est trop con pour
trouver un mari mais bien parce qu'elle
a choisi le célibat est pourquoi at elle
choisi le célibat mesdames les jurés je
m'adresse tout particulièrement à vous
vous savez comment arrêter un homme de
tir air marier l'eau l'homme marié ne
baissent plus est ça ma cliente l'a bien
compris et c'est pour rester combler
qu'elle a choisi le célibat qui l'en
blâmerait vous êtes marié m
je ne suis pas marié
ma cliente est la gentillesse la
courtoisie l'éducation fait femme mais
c'est une femme quant à m c'est une
femme pourquoi les hommes aurait-il le
monopole quoi les vieux aurait le droit
de croquer de la chair fraîche et les
vieilles non je dis c'est juste actifs
du sexisme à monsieur le président du
sexisme tout le monde aime prendre aux
mettre un bon coup
c'est en mode all we need is love
chantait le regretté john mc cartney la
vérité mesdames et messieurs les jurés
ces crédits et daniel ont des besoins
lent comme l'autre mais ils l'expriment
différemment jeudi marion l'est monsieur
le président marionnettes
[Musique]
il m
merci m chabat je vais demander à eddie
barclay de revenir à la barre pour un
instant pour lui demander tout d'abord
si dès qu'il aura divorcé de caroline il
est prêt à épouser danièle gilbert
macha des plantes de
le se compte en banque personnellement
c'est une affaire d'argent sale bête une
affaire d'argent à dosage
mais je pourrais toujours la faire
travailler dans la photo comme vous je
l'avais lié tout à l'heure je pense
qu'il aura encore un bon train la vie
arrières arrières laurière tran huy
puisque moi je ne vous le fais pas dire
vous avez été mariée une fois est-ce que
vous pensez que vous avez rendu heureuse
toutes vos compagnes épouse
dans l'ensemble oui je pense donc pas au
moment des ruptures évidemment mais au
début si il a écouté dit barclay je vous
propose de vérifier avec trois d'entre
elles je m'appelle béatrice chatelier
marchand et j'ai épousé dans les années
70 monsieur eddy barclay
c'était mon premier mariage mais lui il
en était à sa quatrième épouse
j'étais tout à ma à mon adolescence à
main j'ai vu monsieur très gentil et qui
avait la même moustache que mon père qui
se ressemblent un peu rappelle michel je
suis originaire de nouvelle-calédonie
est d'ascendance japonaise et française
et sur ma route sans valon route j'ai
rencontré eddie barclay et nous avons
vécu ensemble de 1971 à 1977
je m'appelle daniel je suis artiste
peintre j'étais la sixième femme de du
barclays je me suis mariée avec lui en
82 le journal mon mariage était très
très triste je crois que c'était la plus
belle soirée de ma vie quelle épreuve
j'ai passé ma nuit à céret dépasse
c'était terrible dérive tous les gens
qui arrivent et ils me repérer j'avais
un énorme truc sur la tête est
épouvantable comme idée toi marie très
sérieux très exigeant très
à part les faits tout ça pour moi
c'était presque à la limite de l'ennui
parce que quand quelque chose se répète
trop et trop obligatoires finalement ça
manque de fantaisie
on ne vous demande rien à la limite il
suffit d'être agréable si vous pouvez
être cultivé tant mieux cette souriante
je n'avais jamais rien à décider même
pas d'aller me baigner même pas d'aller
manger du poisson grillé je m'apercevais
que j'étais plus plu à dire que la
maison que je suis papa maman j'ai rien
fait j'ai pu rien faire je suis
mortellement ennuyeux quand on peut
s'occuper de rien on s'ennuie
dramatiquement
je crois qu'à chaque fois peut-être un
n'était pas très clair mais je crois
qu'à chaque fois il était très amoureux
de la femme qui est l'épousé
je crois qu'il est tellement une
personne s'il est amoureux de lui c'est
tout c'est quand même pas qu'ils
s'éclatent complètement qui trouve sa
vie non c'est pas ça du tout chez lui se
croit capable de faire suivre
quels cas s'il a besoin d'être sûr qu'il
doit pas avoir confiance
mais ce que je veux dire je crois que là
elle est la chose qui m'a le fait le
plus de peine et qui m'a le plus choqué
c'est quand j'ai découvert qu'il dit
enregistrer et écoutaient mes
conversations téléphoniques sans que je
le sache
c'était pire que de rentrer lundi celle
du belge aimerait ça faisait longtemps
je voulais partir je sais pas trop m'en
trop comment le dire un petit peu peur
quand même si je revenais et essayer de
m'imposer dans sa manière d'être et de
vivre les choses et je savais que ça
c'était impossible
donc vous l'avez décidé de pas divorcer
elle est partout devant moi je veux pas
divorcer de sa femme reviennent je pas
divorcer c'était la toise yvan c'était
un roman il n'aime pas la femme il n'est
pas gentil avec une femme il s'est un
peu un mirage alouettes et vous attire
dans une vie qui semble merveilleuse et
en fait il n'y a rien pour vous tout est
pour lui
c'est son organisation c'est sa façon de
vivre c'est ce qu'il aime
et puis il faut suire puis c'est tout
quand on s'est séparés vraiment je
pensais qu'il aurait aucun mal à se
retrouver dès les épouses brune et ip et
le l'avenir l'a prouvé il y barclay
c'est quelque chose à ajouter
oui il ya beaucoup de choses il ya des
choses voyait des choses fausses
ah ouais que l'on sont pas les fausses
il ya beaucoup de choses fausses les
écoutes téléphoniques ne jamais exister
d'une part parce que quand je marche je
fais confiance à mes fans je suis avec
une dame je laime elle je fais confiance
complète ma femme se trouve que
certainement trompé derrière justement
celle qui parle si bien chez pas renter
du nobel ont fait pour le vin c'est du
passé
nous sommes enfin je veux dire que il ya
du vrai du faux mais la seule chose qui
suit est vrai c'est que d'abord au
moment où elles se sont elles mêmes
mariée elle m'aimait et le moment je me
suis mariée sur les haies mais d'une
façon totale et qu'après il est arrivé
des histoires dans la ville qui ont fait
que peut-être n'avait-elle pas
suffisamment de personnalité pour
imposer leur façon de vivre ce qui est
tout à fait possible mais
je les ai tout de même bien fait bien
aimé est bien fait vivre si je veux dire
vous êtes quand même un monsieur assez
jaloux vraiment n'est pas forcément à
défaut donc je n'ai pas vraiment eu pas
très jaloux pas mais à la différence du
club lady barclay je vous remercie je
vais demander à votre épouse caroline de
venir à la barre maintenant bonsoir
caroline
vous avez entendu les trois femmes des
du barclays confirmés ou est-ce que vous
infirmez ce qu'elle dit non ça m'a
beaucoup surpris enfin bombe en ce qui
concerne les chaînes mais pour les deux
ans parfois je les connais pas très bien
mais est-ce que je vous aussi vous avez
passé votre nuit de mariage a serré des
pinces ou évidemment quand ils
laisseraient à penser que dit barclays
est un homard et acéré d'accord m chabat
vous avez une question à poser à
caroline caroline avez vous épousez
eddie barclay par amour et si oui
combien de fois par jour
l'épousé par amour évidemment et comme
une fois par jour ça je calcule pas
quand on aime on compare bon autrement
dit si vous voulez en d'autres termes m
chabat aimerait savoir si eddie barclay
et vigoureux comme un jeune homme
pourrait l'être avec une femme de 20 ans
ça va très bien évidemment ça va très
bien m par d'autres questions non
bon je voulais juste savoir et nous
étendrons pas là dessus
s'il est exact qu eddie barclay vous a
offert un compte à la banque du sperme
et une carte bleue pour le retrait en
liquide et si oui combien de fois par an
[Musique]
je lui avais déjà fait c'est bon alors
nous n'attendons aucune réponse
mais merci en tous les cas caroline de
votre courage car je sais que vous étiez
terrorisée à l'idée de venir à cette
barre à roue et que ça n'a pas été aussi
terrible
merci beaucoup je les appelais
maintenant
je vais appeler jean chrysostome dolto
dit carlos à la barre bonsoir carlos
donc s'arranger mais bas mais je préside
nous fait chier
vous avez fait beaucoup de métier dans
votre vie vous a été régisseur
afficheurs chauffeur kinésithérapeute
acteurs et puis maintenant vous êtes
artiste chanteur de variétés témoins et
injustement je voulais venir vous avez
témoignés combien besoin de mariage
d'eddie barclay témoignait trois fois
trois fois que vous avez conscience
d'avoir été par trois fois un faux
témoins d'ailleurs que quand eddie
barclay jurent fidélité à sa femme
vous l'avez forcément qu'au bout de
quelques mois voire quelques années il
va la quitter
non pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
et très sincèrement je trouve que les
demoiselles en soit les anciennes
demoiselle on a pu le constater sur
l'image qu'ils ont dit du mal de cette
union aurait dû vraiment fermer leur
gueule parce qu'à chaque fois qu eddie a
rencontré et épousé une jeune fille
je pense que pour le cas de certaines il
s'est peut-être trompé son nom de jeune
fille il avant c'était par amour vient
suis complètement témoin et je persiste
et signe
et si les v6 de la vie font que
justement on n'est pas assez costaud
pour être la femme de débarquer on
n'avait qu'à pas dire oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis témoin personnellement et un
serment du désarroi des dix à chaque
fois que ça se passait mal
je n'ai pas toujours été d'accord sont
ses choix mais il faut dire que c'est
plutôt lui qui a été laissé tomber à
chaque fois et quelquefois faut bien le
dire plutôt elle qui s'en vont jouer
cette fois c'est ce qu'on peut demander
à mon caméra de dire si jamais lui qui a
viré quelqu'un disant qu'à ce plat sur d
une fois sur deux mais enfin de dire
quand ça se passait moi je ne pense à
spasm avec tous les deux étaient
d'accord pour se séparer bons c'est
difficile et tendue marquée c'est très
dur j'ai même pas essayé moi même je
serais pas d'accord
m je voudrais pas qu'il faudrait de
temps je crois qu'ils aient dit aurait
mérité d'être un petit l'un des seuls
catholiques bisontin de pouvoir avoir à
rennes parce que je viens je crois qu'il
est capable de sustenter et de donc
physiquement mais besson fiscalement
quelques jeunes filles en même temps et
que celles qui n'ont pas goûté c'est un
peu de l'espoir elle va celles qui
augmentent elles n'ont peut-être pas
tout à fait méritée et je pense que
daniel gilbert devrait devenir un petit
peu sa maîtresse dans l'entente pour
peut-être expliquer aux célibataires que
c'est pas moi je sais ce que souhaitait
également mettre à chamars
notre jolie vous à une question à poser
au témoin oui je voudrais demander à
carlos est peut-être un peu personnel
mais qu'est-ce qu'il avait pris comme
dessert au mariage numéro 6 des 10 et 11
i 30 10 qui vous a vu avec une omelette
norvégienne hilux avec une coupe mais le
bas parce que j'ai un contrôle fiscal là
et vous pouvez pas savoir comme santa
tillon alors léon zitrone
de toute façon comme c'est un mec qui
piquent dans les mariages n'hésitez pas
avec les trucs qu'ils pêchent plein de
domaines
du luxe à mon avis en mariage au
troisième c'est une leçon de télé qu'on
va lui proposer
mais je pense que toute façon il ya des
choses qu'il faut dire c'est que il ya
un certain côté fantastique qui est
magnifique je pense que le jour est du
bluff et n'existera plus hier le show
business il y aura plus de ya plus de
shows en irak du business edit le seul
vivant
le seul témoin vivant est le seul
représentant du show dans le show
business et je suis là je veux remercier
garros je crois que les joueurs ont été
sensibles à votre témoignage
[Musique]
je les appelais de nouveaux danièle
gilbert
à la barre et daniel nous avons un
document un autre encore à verser à
votre dossier voir et l'entendre tout de
suite harry vers 1h 1h états unis ça
dépend des jours où ça dépend des
rendez-vous qu'elle a et c'est tout
chaud septembre c'est la tant convoitée
l'entrée on peut pas échapper
elle attend le poulet au vinaigre et au
miel et un patou chaud tu t es à la fin
apprend le gingembre et le gingembre
c'est un jeu de tir - aphrodisiaques
je sais que c'est en effet vous pensez
que sanaa je pense oui et pour la poser
la question la veille d'accord mais dit
si elle se met tous les midis là c'est
peut-être aussi pour rencontrer l'homme
de sa vie
peut-être est-ce qu'elle a des chances
de le rencontrer ici mais je ne sais pas
il faut la poser la question
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un autour de sa
caméra qu'ils veuillent épouse danièle
gilbert
j'ai dit non
physique c'est pas mal trouvé sommes pas
vrai mais c'est peut-être trouvé des
mélanges nous fait trop mais je parie
qu'en métropole
j'aime parler
dommage pour un jeu non
c'est vrai qu'au point de vue corps au
très sympathique attendait parce qu'elle
s'est lancée dans la chanson
oui tout ça vous allez me dire si vous
êtes séduit
[Musique]
que ce soit
ok à mon avis
tout ça
baie mahault
au caire
la péniche au nom
selon l'onu elle vous emballe ou pas
elle vous emballe ou pas vous craquez la
voix elle est très sensuelle
c'est un régime que j'écouterais
religieusement personnellement et vous
croyez qu'elle se mariera jours
je n'arrive vraiment pas l'avoir mari
d'abord avec les objets c'est bon mais
vous voulez vraiment pas non moi soyez
oeuvres humanitaires
oui mais j'ai pas un esprit de sacrifice
des personnes qui puissent s y
intéresser son immense pendant 20 ans et
être déjà tout fripé de bière pourquoi
le toujours que marié pense qu'elle n'a
pas encore rencontré tout simplement
oui d'accord bon ton pour y donner votre
numéro de téléphone personnel ou
on a recueilli les réponses dont nous
avons le numéro de téléphone de jeunes
hommes et ça n'est pas une plaisanterie
vous en disposez si vous le souhaitez
mais ce que je voulais vous dire vous
avez bien servir des agences
matrimoniales c'est pas la peine non
mais nous ne cherchons absolument pas
vous marier mais tout simplement cherché
à me caser un moment mais nous cherchons
à comprendre pourquoi vous n'êtes pas
encore mariés ça me coûterait de
l'argent ailleurs nous avec tous les
tous les charmes dont vous disposez
c'est ce qui nous étonne daniel croyez
le bien
on pourrait tout à fait honnête danièle
gilbert je voulais vous signaler que
tous les hommes à qui on demandait si
vous leur plaisir et qui étaient
accompagnés n'osais pas dire que vous
leur plaisir alors que les autres disait
était plutôt favorable une un contact
avec vous mélangez vous dire être
célibataire ça ne veut pas dire être
solitaire à eau pas confondre faites
nous une révélation daniel j aucune
révélation vivez-vous tard donc lé vous
avez un homme dans votre vie peut-être à
le busines leur demeure vous n'êtes pas
un certain journal
c'est vrai daniel je vais vous demander
de regagner votre place déjà ah oui tout
à fait je suis allé au teint su vous
désolez leur premier est le premier
témoin s'il vous plaît dit gers et jean
yves rogale que j'appelle à la barre
maintenant monsieur jean yves rogale
s'il vous plaît les tarifs
c'est vous dire un texte je suis fragile
à mes heures si tu me prends que ce soit
fait en douceur fais-moi la bouche un
bien pardon tu me prends que ce soit
bien en douceur que ce soit j'ai entendu
ça vous ça vous dit quelque chose
à moi oui oui tout le temps bien sûr si
vous êtes l'auteur de c'est absolument
n'avez pas eu non pas du tout non mais
je parle à monsieur regard las pour lui
demander s'il n'a pas sonné on va écrire
des paroles de la chanson de daniel
gilbert si je suis témoin de daniel oui
parce que je connais daniel d'accord et
que je sais qu'elle fonctionne en tant
que célibataire bien dans sa tête mais
elle utilise très bien son corps voilà
vous pouvez en témoigner je le sais
parce que je suis je suis ami de daniel
gilbert ne peut pas donner preuve voilà
gmail aucune preuve la parole voilà des
révélations forte intéressante
vous avez une explication au fait
qu'elle ne soit toujours pas mariée à
l'âge de 45 ans oui tout à fait le
dernier gilbert c'est un paradoxe à
savoir que le doubs et je crois pour l a
prouvé je pense je vais pas donner je
souhaite pas faire de révélations elle
est douée pour une vie à deux elle est
douée pour le grand amour elle veut des
choses total et je crois que les vivres
eh bien cela dit le paradoxe vient de là
c'est quelqu'un de aussi complètement
indépendant est complètement libre et
c'est très difficilement conciliables
cela étant dit en tant que
personne libre elle vit très bien très
bien
m chabat vous avez une question à poser
objection votre honneur oui alors laissé
veille oui l objection
non j'ai toujours rêvé de dire cette
phrase aurait comme j'habitais
ce n'est pas de
pas de questions partie du match
question carrière je demande simplement
la clémence du jury pour les paroles de
la chanson pour tous pour tous merci
beaucoup jean yves le gall ont fait
remettre
ce jury il va devoir répondre à trois
questions il va quitter cette salle
maintenant pour se rendre dans la salle
des délibérations et il va devoir
répondre donc je vous le rappelle à la
question à la première question la vie
d'edie barkley est elle une réussite ou
un échec
la deuxième question est là vous serez
probablement d'accord avec moi m chabal
a dit de danièle gilbert était une
réussite ou un échec et la troisième
question qui découle des deux premières
et ils vont de se marier en 1988 ou pas
moi je crois était président âgé parce
que le mariage si ce temps quelque chose
pas que ce soit important mais tu
t'engages suçant s'engage mais en face
il faut penser à l'avenir de tous en
ciel s'il n'y a pas de familles n'ont
plus rien il suffit uniquement dans
l'égoïsme ses capacités de l'égoïste
j'estime que c'est un échec
et moi j'ai été très frappé par
l'équation qu'à établir des témoins
entre mariage et show-business la corde
et disparaît il n'y a plus rien n'y a
plus show business parce qu'elle ne se
mariera plus on en parle moins mariage
c'est pas du show business ont connu les
plus grands il aimait huit femmes dans
sa vie ce mariage est les rendre
heureuse et que c'est pas impossible
le par plusieurs mariages d'ailleurs par
montagny faire aussi est-ce que c'est un
échec ou une réussite de notre série
matt est d'avoir ma famille pour moi
c'est un échec
resté seul sens premier de léo le
mariage se sent bien avec ça en même
temps elle pousse à tout sourit je veux
dire quand on voit ce qu'elle fait vis à
vis des bouquins le cul par exemple on
peut quand même se dire qu'elle a un
site quand même certains hommes à avoir
les yeux fixés sur elle donc ça veut
dire qu'elle souhaitait sachant ce
qu'elle veut exactement à part moi c'est
parce qu'elle a peut d'ailleurs de là
dessus sont pas fixés l'abri pas trop
tard donc c'est un échec
elle a dit être célibataire une radio
n'est moins sûr pourquoi te sens où
c'est un échec parce que pour une pour
moi personnellement le mariage quelque
chose de très important
si ça permet de créer une famille
d'avoir une ambiance familiale d'avoir
tout un cercle
oui je suis marié en fait c'est ce
qu'elle finit par higuain
il n'est pas mort annoncée par carey ya
une différence est que daniela plus tard
alors les moyens de se payer un gigolo
alors que toi non mais je vis quelque
chose
voilà comment important dans cette
première de star à la barre le jury va
maintenant répondre aux trois questions
qui ont été posées
philippe germa et le président de ce
jury alors jeté monsieur le président le
jury a délibéré et de façon assez
accablantes pour vos invités puisque à
la première question la vie d'edie
barclays est elle un échec ou une
réussite
cinq des sept jurés ont considéré que
c'était un échec
en ce qui concerne danièle gilbert les
mêmes jurés ont répondu à la même
question et ont considéré à cinq voix
contre deux que c'était un échec aussi
même ce que enfin il y avait une
question morale à cette émission
et à la question est il bon de se marier
en 88
les jurés sont à cinq voix contre deux
dit oui et peut-être sur ce point
rejoint utile peut-être monsieur
barclays très bien
10dans nous pouvons nous dire quelque
chose en fait car il ne faut pas oublier
quand même que la vie est bien les
hasards de la vie font que peut-être on
se marie on ne se marie pas et que
qu'après tout en faisant le métier que
je fais et surtout quand j'ai fait 13
ans une émission tous les jours je pense
qu'il aurait été très égoïste de faire
des enfants et d'être une maman qui
n'est jamais là et qui confier ses
enfants à des étrangers
et c'est peut-être pour cette raison que
je ne me suis pas marié allez donc
savoir
et bien en prenant bonne note eddie
barclay à un commentaire non un
commentaire ou un commentaire même
peut-être de même peut-être 3 le premier
commentaire c'est qu'il faut déjà un
certain courage pour se marier et pour
au lieu d'avoir des petites amies qui
pourrait passer inaperçu ou mal vivre
peuvre être mon aimée mais mon épaule
yume épouse et mener une vie qu'ils
peuvent entreprendre dans de bonnes
conditions avec comme je vous le disais
mais avec l'amour que je leur porte et
qui est un amour tout à fait sincère
dans une activité qui généralement les
séduit puisque cela c'est notre activité
à tous du show glisse de la chanson
celle de la création
la deuxième chose c'est que je comprends
très bien daniel gilbert parce
qu'effectivement elle fait pratiquement
un métier d'homme et que c'est très
difficile de faire des enfants dans ces
conditions ces considérations là nouveau
merci entre les cartes de vous êtes
prêter à ce jeu pour cette première
émission il fallait quand même du
courage et
et nous en sommes tout à fait conscients
que vous demander d'ailleurs d'applaudir
et du parquet
vous ne m'en voudrez pas si je vous dis
que maintenant nous allons passer les
choses beaucoup plus sérieuses le
mariage mixte les mariages mixtes
en réalité le terme est mal choisi car
il ne convient pas mariages mixtes c'est
généralement de mariage entre chrétiens
qu'il s'agit lorsqu'on parle des
mariages buts mais ce que nous allons
voir et plus particulièrement consacrée
au mariage entre musulmans et chrétiens
avec ce soir et pour la première fois
deux avocats ont plaidé en direct devant
les caméras
il s'agira de mettre lombard et de
maître vergès mais voyons maintenant un
bref rappel de ce qui s'est passé en ce
qui concerne les mariages mixtes entre
musulmans et chrétiens
humour voyons tout ça avec thierry aisne
quoi de plus normal et bien non pas du
tout pourquoi parce que si le papa est
algérien la mer elle est d'une autre
nationalité
le scénario est toujours le même je
t'aime tu m'aimes
on se marque et oui mais après le
mariage s'est dit donc
viens voir dans mon pays comme les
mosquées sont jolies et l'art les
problèmes commencent pour la mer car
elle ne peut pas s'intégrer n'étant pas
musulmane alors à bout de nerfs qu'est
ce qu'elle fait et bien il retourne chez
elle et elle se bat chaque jour pour
récupérer ses enfants
les médias en ont parlé de plus en plus
georgina dufoix est monté aussi auprès
de son petit il faut qu'ils soient pas
leur mère c'est beaucoup de bon sens et
beaucoup d'humanité
le gouvernement algérien lui à écouter
au pas toujours des deux oreilles une
commission franco algérienne s'est créé
et des tribunaux français mais aussi
algériens se sont prononcés pour la
garde de l'enfant à la mère est une
journaliste de libé qui m'a dit que mon
fils était là vous croyez que c'est
normal au bout de onze ans vous
reconnaissez même pas l'enfant que vous
avez ignoré son fils on m'aurait dit que
c'était bien je prenais pour le mien
faisait pas de cas malgré ces propos
plutôt dur certains père refuse encore
les visites alors la commission s'est
réunie en août et après une grande
décision
la mère pourra garder l'enfant si le
père a un droit de visite
et oui mais rien n'est parfait puisque
le droit français lui interdit la visite
on se méfie des enlèvements
qu'à cela ne tienne on changera le droit
ça c'était en août
mais aujourd'hui on en parle encore à
alger puisqu'il faut maintenant que les
tribunaux algériens reconnaissent les
décrets français art pas facile un
imbroglio juridique loin d'être terminée
[Musique]
pour le cas d'armelle boichut ça s'est
fini plutôt bien elle retrouve en france
son mari et ses enfants une famille ce
retrait sous les yeux des enfants des
enfants qui eux n'en croit pas du tout
leurs yeux regarder mais surtout n'allez
pas croire que tout est réglé armelle
boichut c'est un des 50 cas résolus sur
les 300 femmes allemandes françaises
danoise qui se bat pour récupérer leurs
enfants des enfants qui n'ont même pas
le droit de choisir dans quel pays
veulent vivre et qui hésitent encore à
grandir
tellement les adultes eux sont bêtes
[Applaudissements]
vers appelé dire au jury puisqu'il les
connaît déjà mais je les lui rappelle
pour les téléspectateurs les trois
questions auxquelles il va devoir
répondre ce soir le mariage mixte tout
d'abord c'est la première question est
il possible
deuxième question une croyance commune
est-elle nécessaire pour réussir son
mariage
troisième question baisse nilsen dont
vous entendrez l'histoire dans un tout
petit moment baisse nilsen at elle eu
raison ou tort d'agir ainsi
c'est m lombard qui va devoir défendre
baisse nilsen ce soir béni hsen qui est
une danoise dont le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est qu'elle a manqué son mariage
mixte m lombard bonsoir vous venez
d'écrire un livre qui s'appelle le
crépuscule des juges et vous dénoncez
dans ce livre les maux dont souffre la
justice entre autres la politisation
dites-vous de certains magistrats
l'inexpérience des jeunes jugent les
inculpations abusive etc
mais vous ne vous contentez pas de
dénoncer vous essayez également
d'apporter un ou plusieurs remèdes à
cette grande maladresse que j'ai raison
la justice française grande malade il
faut rien exagérer disons simplement que
la justice a besoin d'un sérieux lifting
très bien merci m et puis pour évoquer
la réussite d'un mariage mixte cette
fois c'est maître vergès qui bonsoir m
qui a écrit un autre livre la beauté du
crime
vous êtes auteur donc de ce journal
intime qui à un titre qui finalement est
un petit peu à votre image j'ai envie de
dire que certains
vous haïssent probablement d'autres vous
adule vous êtes quelqu'un qui fascinait
en tous les cas qui déroutait j'appelle
tout de suite à la barre aïcha dogan
[Musique]
bonsoir aïcha dogan vous avez 28 ans
vous êtes marié depuis cinq ans à
mustafa dogan vous êtes française c'est
exact vous êtes né ou marseille
vous êtes converti à l'âge de 16 ans à
l'islam
et ceci parce que votre mère était déjà
mais n'essayez pas sur les influences de
mamers et dunker d'une corbeille cette
idée très bien tous les cas avec vous
nous verrons vous êtes venu en compagnie
de mustapha votre mari nous verrons ce
qu'est un mariage mixte réussi puisque
actuellement
vous vivez visiblement très heureuse
dans le calvados avec trois enfants et
vous étiez chrétienne vous êtes devenue
musulmane
je vais vous demander d'aller rejoindre
votre place aux côtés de jacques vergès
et j'appelle maintenant à la barre
baisse nilsen
[Musique]
je
bonsoir baisse nilsen vous êtes venus ce
soir en compagnie de votre fils jamal
que l'on entendra tout à l'heure vous
êtes danoise et vous avez rencontré
alors que vous viviez au danemark et ça
cette histoire est racontée dans un
livre dont vous êtes l'héroïne livre
écrit par marco koskas qui s'appelle
l'étrangère vous avez rencontrés à l'âge
de 14 ans oui alors que vous viviez
visiblement assez heureuse avec des
parents qui ne s'entendait peut-être pas
très bien trop bien non vous rencontrez
un garçon 18 ans qui est brun basané et
alors là vous êtes complètement séduite
oui oui c'était quelqu'un de tellement
différent parce que le danemark à ce
moment là était que peuple et des blancs
alors je rencontre donc cet homme qui
était très ouvert au monde et qui était
très sûr de ce qu'il voulait et elle ce
dépôt claj était très doué pour faire
des bêtises pour trouver mes parents
j'ai pas pu est alors à la place je suis
parti loin
alors partez vous quittez votre famille
à l'âge de 14 ans il en a même trop 17
ans à 17 ans vous partez avec ce garçon
et il vous emmène à l'étranger il faut
préciser qu'il est au fln que c'est la
guerre d'algérie et que vous allez
devoir attendre 1962 pour retourner en
algérie
alors comment ça se passe votre arrivée
en algérie ça se passe bien
passez d'abord quand j'arrive à
l'aéroport je peux pas je reconnais pas
mon mari parce qu'il ressemble à tout le
monde alors c'était
un char libéral fabuleuse que vous aviez
en avant non alors c'est déjà un premier
choc après mon gros problème c'est que
j'ai parlé ni lara pini le français qui
fait que j'avais beaucoup de mal d'avoir
communiqué avec les gens et là à petit à
petit commence donc tu es enfin des
difficultés avec un culture aussi
différents que les miens bon à ce moment
là votre mari voyage beaucoup ils
voulaient seul très souvent vous vivez
visiblement de manière assez
indépendante pas indépendants non parce
que j'étais tout le temps plus ou moins
surveillés par la famille gd rarement
seul il y avait toujours une des
sessions l'a pas trop non pas au début
jusqu'au jour où il se rend compte que
vous l'avait trompée et alors là que se
passe-t-il ben que mes deux belles mères
s'installe à la maison et que j'ai plus
le droit de sortir alors là on veut
faire de vous une femme soumise jouer on
veut faire de moi une vraie musulmans et
ça vous ne souhaitiez pas non vous ne
saviez pas qu'en citant d'autres pays en
allant en algérie avec un musulman vous
alliez non comment on peut le savoir
avant d'avoir vécu et quand la 17 temps
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que quand on
peut savoir par rapport à une culture
c'est différent très bien de votre union
quand même mené un enfant il s'appelle
jamal nous l'avons vu il est maintenant
comédien sait rien un grand garçon et
lui même marié il ad il a une petite
fille je crois et puis il ya un moment
très dur c'est le moment où finalement
votre mari vous enlevez jamal une
première fois
oui le ramener en europe vous avez un
coup de chance inouïe en passant l
aéroport le fait passer dans les dents
les enfants de avait bondi donc on ne
parle mais là votre mari enlève de
nouveaux jamal et puis un beau jour
l'enlever de nouveau
et puis ça recommence dans l'autre sens
deux fois donc jamal a été enlevé et
puis un beau jour votre mari rentre avec
jamal il arrive au danemark
il est chassé de son pays pourrait-on
dire pour des raisons politiques il et
objectivité le pays
et là vous lui proposez de garder
l'enfant bien sûr mais vous lui donner
en contrepartie de l'argent c'est comme
ça que l'histoire se termine avec une
scène dont je voudrais quand même de
lire un extrait c'est écrit dans le
livre au moment où l'enfant ou de jamal
arrive vous êtes avec lui et son et
votre mari moncef tour à tour ils
grimpaient sur mes genoux puis aller se
blottir contre moncef comme pour nous
montrer à l'un et à l'autre qu'il
n'arriverait jamais à choisi ce moment a
dû être terrible à vivre très bien basse
nixen jeu
je vais demander à m lombard s'il a une
question à vous poser
oui oui j'ai une question à poser parce
que je voudrais que les choses soient
claires et si on lit votre livre un peu
rapidement
on est tenté de penser qu'il a une
connotation raciste et qui je croyais
pas du tout dans votre esprit
il faudrait d'abord que vous expliquer
là dessus parce que si naturellement aux
cette affaire avait une connotation
raciste serait pas ce dont beaucoup
d'efforts par conséquent expliquez vous
aux téléspectateurs
non mais c'est une histoire d'amour
alors je vois pas où on met le racisme
là dedans donc il n'ya pas de racisme et
il y a juste mon affrontement avec un
autre culture qui si différents y'a pas
de visiblement non plus de problème de
religion non non c'est vraiment lui
n'est pas pratiquants non il est papa tu
crois qu'il faudrait que vous demandiez
où monsieur le président si madame
nielsen et pratiquante aussi non je le
suis pas et je n'étais pas par
conséquent c'est un problème de culture
qui à un moment donné quelconque vous à
n'ont pas opposé mais qui vous à qui
vous a surpris que vous à peu près à la
gorge saison à oui c'était un choc c'est
un chacun venant du danemark qui était à
ce moment là un pays très avant-garde
c'était un très grand choc moi vous
laisser partir à l'âge enfin vous
laisser fréquenter un homme de 18 ans à
l'âge de 14 ans est ce que c'était
les moeurs était tellement libéré qu'on
puisse faire une chose pareille
moi j'avais des parents aussi très
avant-garde mais qui étaient dans leurs
propres problèmes et est en train de
divorcer
j'aimerais maître vergès vous avez une
question à poser à bessines scène oui je
voudrais d'abord je voudrais dire que je
ne peux pas considérer baisse les scènes
ici comme un adversaire que je voudrais
cuisine et je ne voudrais pas à rappeler
beaucoup d'éléments qui sont dans son
livre mais est ce qu'elle pense qu'un
mari auvergnats breton belge aurait pris
d'une meilleure façon
la découverte que sa femme le trompait
bc l'adultère qui dans cette affaire est
à l'origine
non mais à la séparation je suis
d'ailleurs pas loin de penser comme vous
et bien alors nous sommes d'accord pour
une fois donc c'est la question que je
loupe
c'est la question que vous posez je
pense comme harry auvergnats belge
bretons se serait comporté en général de
la même manière que se marient algérien
qui n'était pas pratique en importe quel
mal d'ailleurs question que je posais
n'était pas une question polémique
s'était tout simplement pour vous poser
cette
des styles scène je pense messieurs que
nous pouvons vous demander de retourner
vous asseoir car j'appelle à la barre
maintenant aïcha dogan d'alors aïcha
vous al'inverse de baisse nilsen vous
avez je le disais tout à l'heure
visiblement réussi votre mariage avec
mustapha expliquez nous comment vous
comment vous vivez
moi ça me paraît assez extraordinaire
vous vivez au milieu du calvados
vous êtes musulmane vous parler avec un
accent marseillais je pense les gens à
vouloir un petit peu je pense que que
les gens là-bas ne doivent rien
comprendre comment ça se passe à vrai
dire quand je dis que je suis française
et musulmane ne comprennent pas ça fait
dix points d'interrogation dans leur
tête
10 oui oui mais comprennent pas ce qu
est ce que votre mari lorsque vous
l'avait épousée vous imposer certaines
règles vous viviez déjà avec un voile
sur la tête avec les mains et l'ovale du
visage découvert maître vergès de
questions à poser à erdogan
oui une question simple est ce que vous
êtes heureuse tout à fait je suis très
heureuse un mari un couple trésor les
gens heureux n'ont pas d'histoire je
n'ai pas d'autres questions et précis
merci m m non barre oui je pense que il
y à une question qui me paraît très
important
le grand philosophe lévi-strauss
philosophe français dit que les
différences attire et que les
similitudes retiennent alors est ce que
vous avez trouvé avec votre époux des
similitudes qui vous ont retenu je parle
pas si vous voulez sur le plan amoureux
je parle sur le plan de la culture
oui déjà et avec lui les musulmans et
moi aussi déjà ça fait un grand point
entre nous qui nous unit et en plus de
ça en un caractère qui se lit facilement
c'est une facile de
de pratiquer votre religion quand on vit
en france comme ça oui ça vient du coeur
si elles veulent pratiquer en pratique
en plus d'enfants ça n'a pas de
difficultés merci beaucoup je crois que
votre témoignage était important je vais
vous demander de rejoindre votre place
et j'appelle le premier témoin de baisse
nilsen son fils jamal
bonsoir jamal vous êtes vous êtes
maintenant comédien oui c'est ça ça va
ça marche bien ça va bon j'aimerais
savoir ce que vous avez conservé comme
rapports avec vos parents ou qui vivent
séparés loin l'un de l'autre et après
avoir lu cette histoire est vécu cette
histoire
écoutez ça ça se passe jusqu'à ce que
j'ai l'âge de quatre ans donc je me suis
pas grand chose sinon aujourd'hui j'ai
de très bons rapports avec mes parents
pas de problème je m'entends bien avec
mon père je m'entends bien quand même
vous avez lu le livre oui est ce que ça
a changé votre jugement
lorsqu'enfin si vous aviez un jugement à
porter sur votre mère ou sur votre père
non comment est ce que vous avez vécu la
lecture de ce livre j'imagine ça n'a pas
dû être très drôle alliés mais moi je
voulais vu comme un roman voilà avec un
peu de distance mais sans imaginer un
seul instant qu'il s'agissait de votre
père votre maître vous merci quand même
est-ce que vous souvenez de moments
précis dans cette histoire ou pas du
tout non et vous n'êtes pas d'accord
quand on vous dit que votre votre mère
entre guillemets vous a racheté à votre
père j'ai lu ça dans une interview à mon
avis
je sais pas en fait
est ce que m lombard à une question à
poser à demain mais d'abord je ne peux
pas laisser passer le mot rachat parce
que à aucun moment dans le livre il
s'agit d'un rachat simplement le père de
jamal était dans une situation
financière difficile
madame nilsen était dans une situation
financière meilleure et je crois qu'elle
l'a aidée à passer un cap difficile
parce que le mot rachat possède une
connecte à sion désagréable c'est le
moins qu'on puisse mettre jolie quand
même je peux t'aider tu sais je suis
même prête à te payer pour que tu me
rendes jamal combien veut tuer vous
savez dans les couples qui ne sont pas
des couples qui se posent sur le plan de
la culture
il ya des questions financières dans
tous les divorces du monde c'est évident
c'est pas simplement les mariages mixtes
qui donnait à ces sortes de d'accord
maître vergès une question radjah man je
voudrais dire à jabal que je suis moi
même fils d'un couple mixte et que donc
quand je lui pose des questions c'est
une manière parfaitement
je voudrais dire très proche est-ce
qu'il se sent qu'on est ce qu'il se sent
pas un peu mutilé dans sa partie
algérienne parce que il est un être
complexe
est ce qu'apple partie algérienne qui
lui manque un peu pas totalement mais un
peu non non c'est tout
merci diamal vous pouvez regagner votre
place j'appelle maintenant la barre
mustafa dogan
bonsoir mustapha bon votre épouse disait
qu'elle était tout à fait heureuse
vous êtes un mari comblé il ya eu
vraiment aucun problème le jour où vous
avez décidé de l'épouser
c'est à dire les crampons se décide de
marier il faut au réseau dans le mariage
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
et il ne faut pas se marier je crois
seulement avec le sentiment
oui il faut compter sur le sentiment les
époux devront semaine pour accomplir
leur union mais et comme le mariage est
une hâte qu'on peut aller jusqu'à le
mois il faut bien peser
qu'est ce que ça veut dire la notion de
mariage et nous nous sommes posés entre
nous je crois avec ma femme on est
réfléchi pendant trois mois avoir de
décider et moyens que nous nous sommes
unis en demandant un bon sens il est mis
d'accord avant vous saviez elle savait
qu'elle devait
suivre et vivre selon certaines règles
elle était très fort et vous êtes marié
à prèsent vous êtes entendus oui bien
sûr elles montraient que les musulmans
elle est élevé dans la culture
occidentale et moi j'ai une culture
orientale montré que je vise c'est quand
même mon mariage
après sept ans en france que je
connaissais un peu mais ça méritait
d'être posée en mariage certaines
questions
on peut en voir ou bien supposer qu'il
peut avoir certains problèmes il faut
discuter auparavant
il faut sérieuse sur une base solide
mais trop vergès vous à une question à
poser à mustafa dogan
oui sa femme est musulmane s'est
convertie avant le mariage étant des
conditions donc entièrement indépendante
du mariage je voudrais lui poser la
question
sa femme qui se bat yam explique
véronique aussi est ce qu il considère
sa femme comme une française tout avril
et culturels oui tout à fait je
considère comme une française musulmane
comme je suis un clic origine musulmane
m lombard une question est ce que vous
auriez épouse et votre femme si elle
avait conservé sa religion d'origine
c'est-à-dire comme j'ai essayé
d'expliquer si on peut raisonner qu'est
ce qu'il peut apporter la croyance comme
ron le mariage
on pourrait décider de se marier tout à
fait je suis pour qu'on puisse se
marièrent tout en connaissant les pauses
qui peut venir appelle des problèmes qui
peuvent se poser après il faut se poser
des questions avant de décider très bien
merci merci beaucoup
mustapha nous allons passer maintenant
aux plaidoiries
alors notre tribunal je le disais en
début de cette émission n'est pas un
tribunal comme les autres et nous avons
procédé à un tirage au sort nous avons
joué à pile ou face avant l'émission
l'ordre de passage des plaidoiries et
c'est maître vergès qui va plaider le
premier m
sur le président mesdames messieurs les
jurés vous avez remarqué qu'ici ce soir
et pour une fois et je m'en félicite
je ne plaide pas contre quelqu'un je
plaide pour l'évidence trois questions
vous sans poser je voudrais que vous
voulez posiez dans un sens dans un ordre
légèrement différent premièrement ce
mariage si at il été un échec
deuxièmement celui là at il était une
réussite et c'est seulement après avoir
constaté les causes de cet échec et les
causes de cette réussite que vous
pourrez répondre à la première question
que je place en 3e
est ce que le mariage mixte est possible
premièrement vous avez remarqué que
avocats de madame dogan
j'ai témoigné envers madame nilsen et
envers son fils je dirais plus que de la
compréhension à l'égard du fils
certainement de la fraternité
cependant il nous faut analyser les
causes de cet échec
on a présenté ce mariage comme un
mariage mixte un mariage mixte entre
deux personnes qui ne sont pas
pratiquants et madame nilsen nous a dit
elle-même que son mari ne pratiquait pas
et qu'elle ne pratique de sorte que nous
sommes tout à fait en dehors du cadre du
mariage mixte et plus précisément du
mariage européen est originaire d'un
pays où l'islam est la religion
prédomine et à travers malgré les
questions feutrée que j'ai posée est
volontairement parce que je ne tiens
blessé ici la pudeur et l'intimité de
personnes
vous avez deviné que ce mariage a abouti
à un échec pour des raisons qui ferait
aboutir à un échec
un mariage un autre mariage qui ne
serait pas mixtes vous à rappeler l'âge
de madame nilsen quand elle s'est
fiancée 14 et son époux son futur époux
18 ans on ne nous a pas rappelés mais je
peux me le permettre puisque madame
nilsen le dit dans son livre qu'à l'âge
de 14 ans elle avait déjà s'était déjà
fait avorter une fois et que pendant ses
fiançailles elle a été enceinte d'un
autre homme qui se croyait lui même son
fiancé le mari évidemment d'ignorer ils
vont en algérie dans des conditions
matérielles très difficile à travers
l'allemagne l'italie la libye enfin
l'algérie l'algérie du début de
l'indépendance où il ya un certain chaos
économique et beaucoup de difficultés et
à ce moment là il le dit dans son lit au
bout de quelques mois elle se laisse
séduire par un homme qui est beaucoup
plus responsable que son mari son mari
un poste dans un ministère mais cet
homme qu'elle appelle le grand manitou
apparemment une très grosse
responsabilité et sept hommes abusent de
cette autorité fait envoyer le mari en
mission dans le sud pour pouvoir
l'absence du mari au domicile du mari
rendre visite à la personne qu'il
voudrait prendre comme ça pendant
l'absence du mari qui est en mission
elle vient en europe avec cet homme il
dîne à la tour d'argent
est ce que vous croyez que l'échec de ce
mariage vient de sa mixité
voyons maintenant les raisons de la
réussite de l'autre côté et bien dans
l'autre côté il ya évidemment la
religion qui joue un rôle mais son mari
mustapha vous l'a dit ici
cette condition qui est une condition
qui favorise l'harmonie dans le couple à
son avis n'est pas nécessaire qu'il
aurait épousé aussi bien une française
qui aurait été catholique à condition
que les deux époux avant de se marier et
une conversation d'adultes et n'ont pas
d'enfants une conversion d'adultes pour
dire voilà les obstacles culturels qui
existent entre nous entre nos deux
civilisations est ce qu'il est possible
est-ce que nous sommes prêts l'un et
l'autre
faire les concessions et l'effort voulu
pour surmonter ces obstacles
alors je dis que le mariage mixte est
possible il répondit que c'est possible
parce que ces obstacles surmontés
introduisent une nouvelle richesse dans
l'harmonie du couple
vous avez compris désormais quand je
vous disais au départ que je voulais que
je plaidais pour l'évidence en fait je
plaide tout simplement pour l'amour
l'amour qui disait dans tu me le soleil
et les planètes et beaucoup plus
simplement comme disait edith piaf
sans quoi la vie n'est rien du tout
[Applaudissements]
mm les rebelles m lombard c'est à vous
maintenant de tenter de convaincre le
jury de stars à la barre mesdames et
messieurs j'ai quatre minutes pour ou
contre 4 minutes quatre arguments
premier argument contrairement ce que
l'on croit les mariages mixtes ne sont
pas une invention de ce siècle et
mariages mixtes sont aussi vieux que la
femme et l'homme lorsqu'ils ont décidé
d'unir leur destin pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
mariage entre les roturiers les nobles
mariage éternelle entre les riches et
les pauvres je vous renvoie à l'univers
mme alsacien mariage entre ceux qui sont
issus de cultures différentes
par conséquent pourquoi ce débat parce
que les mariages mixtes je prenne pas
cette expression je préfère un mariage
mixte l'expression de mariages inter
culturels sont devenus un phénomène de
société
alors que le nombre des mariages en
france diminue le nombre des mariages
interculturel augmente 8% sur le global
des mariages célébrés en france en 1975
il y à 17500 mariages mixtes
en 1985 un an à près de 23000 et
aujourd'hui vous avez 4000 française ou
français qui épousent uniquement des
algériens des algériens phénomène
extraordinaire de société pour narguer
deuxième argument
est ce que le mariage mixte le maillage
interculturel et un mariage facile je me
permettrai d'abord leur appel à vos
souvenirs
il n'y a pas de marier un facile on fait
lorsqu'on se marie un saut dans
l'inconnu et bertrand de jouvenel avez
raison de dire que les pères et les
mères de famille sans les aventuriers
des temps modernes
mais le mariage mixte à se heurter à
trois rangées de barbelés
d'une part cultures différents d'autre
part législation différents et souvent
religions différentes
alors est ce que on peut passer ces
obstacles
je crois que c'est une question de
civilisation de liberté je disais tout à
l'heure que dieu ne pouvez jamais être
contre la liberté je vous demande de
méditer cet axiome il est certain que le
mariage unique se présente des avantages
très important les quais d'abord ça met
en présence des gens de sensibilité
absolument différente
ensuite ça permet l'intégration alors le
vrai problème est de savoir si l'on peut
réaliser un mariage mixte sans aliéner
sa dignité et sans aliéner son périmètre
de liberté auquel tous les hommes en
droit et toutes les femmes en droit
voilà le vrai problème alors je crois
que par exemple madame de gants et son
mari ont réalisé et vous voyez que je
n'hésite pas à plaider pour le client de
vergès et s'il ya eu un échec
en ce qui concerne ma propre cliente
cela relève davantage de
l'incompréhension de la jeunesse car il
est bien certain lorsque l'on épouse à
14 ans à 16 ans un homme beaucoup plus
âgé que ce soit eh bien on est tenté
davantage que si l'on se marie à l'âge
mûr mais la mixité mariana alors quel
est le vrai danger
le vrai danger c'est que
la culture latino grecque est la nôtre a
une conception binaire du mariage ça
veut dire qu'il ya un duo entre l'homme
et la femme alors que dans la culture
islamique
c'est une chose connue est d'ailleurs
protégé par le code algérien de la
famille il ya une conception peu
familiale il ya un article du code
algérien de la famille qui dit que la
femme doit respecter son mari qui est
chef de famille lui doit la
considération et dont la considération
également je crois que c'est l'article
de 8
la considération également à sa famille
et à ses proches
alors ça peut créer des conflits mais
moi je suis de ceux qui pensent que
l'amour peut résoudre tous les conflits
voilà pourquoi je dis que vous devez
acquitter ma cliente coûts devaient
répondre oui à la question des mariages
mixtes écoute veut dire qu'une croyance
obligatoire et commune n'est pas
obligatoire
et si vous répondez de cette façon là
j'aurais l'impression grâce à vous
d'avoir largement gagné ma soirée
lombard le jury va maintenant quitter
cette salle partir délibérer je vous
rappelle les trois questions qui lui
sont posées dans cette deuxième audience
le mariage mixte est il possible c'est
la première de ces questions deuxième
question une croyance commune est-elle
nécessaire pour réussir son mariage
deuxième question donc et troisième
question
beth din scène at-elle eu raison ou tort
d'agir ainsi
moi je pense que le mariage il mais
c'était impossible parce qu'il ya une
beaucoup parce qu'on s'appelle il est
possible mais il est très difficile
on sait ce que disait je conduis en fait
les deux avocats il ya des différences
de culture des différences de religion
des différences de législation qui
créent des gros problèmes
il est possible à une seule condition
c'est qu'on se mette d'accord avant le
mariage
oui alors bon là je suis d'accord avec
cela mais en fait moi je ne serai plus
dur et je dirais pour moi il n'est pas
possible
attention je ne fais pas de racisme loin
de là mais je dis que le choc la
confrontation des cultures des religions
est telle que même avec l'amour il faut
aussi penser qu'il y ait la vie de tous
les jours qu'ils ont suivie dit qu
impossible pour lier les cultures quel
aveu mais dans une mesure de protection
oui c'est que la hyène différence c'est
que c'est pas le problème est au niveau
des cultures je crois que le problème
est au niveau de l'enseignement ont reçu
justement ceux qui vont se marier de
leurs parents et ce qu'a reçu la mariée
de ses parents tout problème il est là
c'est pas la culture
je lui ai dit alain japon soit noir soit
blanc en soie jaune c'est comment on
élevé qui compte apparemment on n'arrête
pas de faire c'est à dire moi je peux
apprécier ses vergers dans la vie à
quatre jours de leur vie pour moi même
beaucoup
mais qui serait se voyait beaucoup plus
tard il serait peut être important
justement lorsque les problèmes même
dans un ménage et de culture identique
il est important les problèmes existent
aussi c'est de les mettre sur la table
jours mais il existe ne pas attendre
qu'ils oui bien sûr grand bien sûr mais
des problèmes il y en a déjà
j'allais dire tellement voilà pendant
que le jury délibère je vous propose
ce qui sera pour beaucoup d'entre vous
une découverte nous avons demandé par
petite annonce à des couples de religion
différente de nous faire parvenir le
film de leur mariage sont des films
amateurs bien entendu en voici un
montage dans lequel nous allons vous
allez probablement découvrir des
traditions différentes des rites
différents
un mariage musulman c'est une fête où
les rites qui l'accompagnent varie d'une
région où d'un pays à l'autre
elle peut durer plusieurs jours ponctuée
de différentes cérémonies
pendant les jours qui précèdent le
mariage la mariée préparé par d'autres
femmes loin des regards masculins et
surtout de celui du mari ses doigts sont
teintées aux aînés et la veille du
mariage elle est totalement épilé de la
tête aux pieds
enfin le soir du grand jour les familles
accompagnent les époux jusqu'à la porte
de leur chambre
le mari devra offrir alors à sa
belle-mère un présent ici une bougie
pour prouver qu'il accepte sa fille pour
le meilleur et pour le pire
contrairement au mariage musulman où il
n'y a que rarement une cérémonie dans un
lieu de culte
le mariage juif se déroule d'abord à la
synagogue fonder une famille et tente
une des obligations de la religion juive
celle ci ne peut se faire sans la
bénédiction du rabbin puis sans boire
quelques gouttes de vin béni d'israël
avant d'échanger les traditionnels
anneaux qui seront portés soit à l'index
pour les plus religieux soit à
l'annulaire enfin après l'échangé des
anneaux
le marié devra jeter par terre un verre
soigneusement emballés s'il se casse le
mariage sera réussi sinon on raconte que
les juifs les plus orthodoxes vont
jusqu'à refaire entièrement la cérémonie
pour les chrétiens orthodoxes les rites
sont souvent totalement différent selon
les régions où les églises ici à chypre
la cérémonie se déroule le dimanche
après une bénédiction des époux par le
prêtre et la pose de deux couronnes les
femmes du village se réunissent pour
bénir le lit du futur foyer des enfants
sont couchés et même des billets de
banque déposé sur un matelas en signe de
fécondité et de prospérité
[Musique]
voilà le jury est revenu dans la salle
d'audience
il va pouvoir maintenant par la voix de
son président philippe germa répondre
aux trois questions qui ont été posées
philippe je vous en prie
écoutez je crois que la limite est c'est
fait dans le jury sur un certain nombre
de positions à la première question le
mariage mixte est il possible
5 les jurés ont répondu oui et de nom à
la seconde question une croyance commune
est-elle nécessaire pour réussir un
mariage mixte
les jurés ont répondu non ils sont
quatre à avoir dit entre 3 wii et enfin
resque bastille scène à tort ou raison
six d'entre nous ont dit qu'elles
avaient raison et une seule
on dit qu'elle avait eu tort
[Musique]
aïcha avec maître vergès vous avez
réussi à convaincre ce jury j'imagine
que vous êtes heureux ce soir
sauf sur eux merci beaucoup m lombard
épaisse mycènes aussi vous avez réussi à
les convaincre baisse vous attendiez à
une autre à con de jury a jeté j'avais
un petit gars que tu je suis très
content d'eux
réponse il ya 5 6 ans pour dopage
dans tous les cas merci tous les cartes
d'avoir participé à cette première de
star à la barre nous vous donnons rendez
vous le mois prochain pour une autre
émission de ce style passez une bonne
fin de soirée sur antenne 2 au revoir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]